okay so i'll be talking about
estimation of low rank matrices and
the age of big data and as as the
distinction we deal with
lots of different kinds of matrices in
high dimensional inference
we work with large covalent matrices or
its inverse
the so-called precision matrices or if
you are working with
graphs or networks you need to deal with
adjacency matrix
and in terms of the structural matrices
we
sometimes deal with sparse matrix banded
matrix
complex matrix and there's a big class
of matrices called the low rank matrix
and low rank matrix is a major
interest mainly because of different
kinds of
applications i think the problem was
made famous by the
netflix problem but it's also
applied in many a wide range of other
problems like image compression facial
recognition and
in particular in quantum computing in
quantum state tomography
a major problem is to estimate the
density matrix which is often
of low rank and there are many problems
different aspects of these type of
problems but the goal is
almost always the same we want to
develop efficient algorithms
to reconstruct matrices from as few
number of measurements as possible
and the problem can be formulated in a
fairly general way
so we have an unknown low rank matrix
called
a we want to recover but we only get to
see
some linear transformation of this
matrix a
x of a and this can be equivalent
written as in terms of matrix regression
uh so you have an unknown matrix you
want to recover
so you measure the matrix through inner
product of a given
of a collection of matrices x i so this
inner product
is just element wise react vectorized in
the product
and the many different
prop many in terms of the linear map
itself
in terms of application sometimes it's
given
in statistics is also often given by in
engineering for example you have the
freedom to choose
how to design the matrix the the map
linear map x so that you can recover
this matrix a
quickly or through small number of
measurements
and this a itself is unknown and
sometimes it's exactly low rank and
sometimes
it's approximately low rank and from
most of the algorithms we wish is to do
well
even if it's not exactly low rank and
they're also in terms of this epsilon
that sometimes it's noiseless so
absolutely zero and sometimes it's noisy
and the goal is try to recover this
matrix a from
those linear measurements so for those
of you who are familiar with
statistics and this is just a matrix
version of linear regression
and in typical linear regression we deal
with vectors
and there's a
growing literature on matrix recovery
especially low rank matrix recovery
and this is by no means exhausted
so a major question is
how can we design or construct
a linear map x equivalently
those measurement matrices x i
to guarantee exact or stable recovery
in the case of noiseless or noisy
noise noisy setting with minimum number
of measurements
and the problem has been
well studied in the vector case in the
vector case if we have
a spa signal beta and we
want to project by a matrix x or
linear regression without noise and what
kind of
x will guarantee the exact recovery in
the noise
noiseless case and it's well known that
randomness is good and it's very hard to
construct
deterministic matrix to guarantee
recovery but it's relatively easy
to construct random matrices
it can be random gaussian it can be
random
sparse or if you are if you are lazy you
can use
plus one minus and life is easy and
simple
as long as the number measurements is
not too small so the basic requirement
is a number of sample
should be order at least k times log p
over k and in this case
the problem is well understood
and in the matrix case it has also been
studied
and for example the work by bankrupt
and candidates and plan they use
gaussian and samples so each
measurement x is an iid gaussian matrix
and as long as n the number of sample
is greater than or equal to some
constant c times
r is the rank and p and q is
the dimension of the matrix and it can
be shown that
with this number of measurements you can
recover the unknown
low rank matrix exactly with a high
probability
but there's only a small problem the
problem is that
we are dealing with matrices so we need
to store all those
n measurement matrix for future use
and the matrix is of order p by q
and you need to keep any of them so you
just come to the number of
entries you need to store up and for do
small calculation p q say equal to a
thousand
and i is ten and by simulation this
constant c is roughly four point
it's not a big constant but still you
need to keep
about 45 000 matrices
and that requires 45 gigabytes
and if you further increase the size
of the matrix slightly by a factor of
10. so you are
trying to recover 10 000 by 10 000
matrix
and rank still keep at 10.
now you need this many
matrices and basically you need to cube
it
so you multiply it by 10 the dimension
is multiplied by 10
now it's 10 to the third and you
multiply together you need
45 terabytes and that means that
you have serious space constraints if
you use
iid gaussian matrices
we are all familiar also with matrix
compression which is a much simpler
design in the sense that each time you
only need to take sub samples
of the matrix and in that case if we
write in this form
x i is simply with one single entry you
go to one the rest are zero
the problem with matrix compression
design is that you are not able to
get guarantee that the recovery of all
low rank matrices
and for example you will never be able
to
recover say a spiked matrix a matrix
with value just say in the extreme case
one
non-zero the rest are all zero if you
simply sample the entries
then with a high probability that you're
not going to be able to see that
non-zero one
and you will never be able to infer the
value of the non-zero
from all other zero observed values
so what we propose is something
different slightly different
from the gaussian matrix and we propose
to
sam using generates gaussian
vectors instead of matrix so let bi
beta i to be iid gaussian random vectors
of dimension p
and gamma i i id gaussian vectors of
dimension q
so it generates those random vectors
and you sample measure the matrix a
through such a linear operation so
you're simply
left to multiply by beta i transpose and
right
multiply by gamma i so in other words
you generate
matrices measurement matrix by
rank 1 operation so x i is simply
beta i gamma i transpose
now you have many measurements of such a
matrix
imagine that we have a more compact form
of writing
the measurements you have n measurements
and for now let's assume that
the measurement error is iid gauss
it doesn't have to be galaxy suppose we
have
such observations can we recover the
matrix
a from x and y
it turns out we can and we
introduce a constrained nuclear
non-minimization
algorithm so we define two convex sets
the first one is very simple it's
a polyatom so it's an
l1 ball the second one is also a
polytope so this
x star is a dual operator of x
and and we form the intersection of the
two sets
so intersection of convex sets are still
convex
and we introduce a constant called eta
now we are going to
estimate the unknown low rank matrix a
by constrained nucleon or minimization
so under the constraint that for any
candidate low rank matrix m
as long as m minus x of m is in that
set g among all those feasible solutions
i want to find the one that
minimize the nucleon so how does this
compare to so you said you know it's not
going to work for spiky
matrices now how would that compare to
sort of just
applying a linear transformation a
random rotation
to the rows into the columns and then
using
that single observation uh that depends
when i said that you cannot recover
spiked matrix
through matrix compression just sample
the entries so with this we will
guarantee that you will recover
the whole matrix any low rank matrix we
don't need any
additional constraints
so and this is obviously
a convex program a convex constraint
with
complex objective function so the
nuclear norm is just the sum of the
singular values so let's just try one
simple example
so let's say we have this grayscale logo
of mit and if you treat this
as a matrix it's a rank six matrix
and now suppose that if we treat this as
a matrix you're left multiply by a
gaussian vector and the right multiplied
by a gaussian vector
and do it many times and apply the
algorithm to recover
and we try three different sample sizes
one is n equal to 800. you try it 800
times
and apply the algorithm you recover that
and it's not too bad but it's not as
clean as that one
now if you further increase the sample
to be
a thousand it's very good and by the
time
it's 1080 you get the original
logo back exactly so it works
reasonably well and we have tried of
course other examples
but we also want to have some
theoretical guarantees
and it can be analyzed and to show that
the estimate a hat under the condition
that
n is greater than or equal to some
constant times rank
times the dimension the difference
between
the estimates and the truth and the
fluidist norm
is upper bound by a quantity
like that and the two features of this
result
one is that we have been assuming that
the measurement
error z follows a gaussian distribution
and in particular if sigma is zero that
means that you have
exact measurements without measurement
error then this side obviously is zero
it means that you will recover
the matrix exactly with a high
probability another thing is
it depends on the measurement the
recovery accuracy depends on the rank
the sample size and also the dimension
and those are obvious
quantities and but if you only have an
upper bound
you're never sure whether there's some
other
method that will out
perform this method much by a
significant amount
so we also obtained some lower bound
results
and the lower boundary result shows that
in over all possible methods so it has
and the chance that the measurement
error is
greater than this quantity is basically
going to one
so in other words you can never be
much better than this and you can also
write this in terms of
instead of high probability you can also
write this in terms of
expectation and also in both
the lower bound and upper bound results
we have
a condition on the sample size
and for the sample size you can also
obtain a lower bound to show that
that sample size requirement is
necessary
if you have sample and if the number of
samples n is less than
this quantity which is the same as here
then
no method will work and this
lower bound is a very simple argument
you just constant number three the
number of three parameters in low rank
matrices for a rank r matrix you do svd
just count how many unconstrained
entries so
so the number of measurements must
satisfy
this minimum requirement and that
requirement by the way it comes from
the simple counting of the three
parameters in the
rank r matrix and also the number of
require the number of samples required
in this case is the same as the number
of samples required for
with gaussian measurement
and if we compare the two bounds the
lower bound and upper bound
you'll see that as long as the rank
r is not too small if rank is
greater than or equal to log of the
dimension then
the method is optimal and
or if r is or if n
is of this exact order and we are still
not sure
what happens if i is very small and so
there's
still some room for
investigation
and by the way the requirements on the
distribution of beta i in the gamma i
can be relaxed it doesn't have to be
gaussian for example you can replace
those gaussian
measurements by iid plus one minus one
that's fine
and also you can extend that to
sub gaussian distributions we do need
some tail
conditions on the distribution of the
measurements
and in some problems although the low
rank matrix is unknown
but we do know that symmetric
if they're symmetric it can be further
simplified
it doesn't you don't really need to have
different
measurement vectors on the two sides you
can just use
a single one beta i you use beta
on the left and also on the right and
the rest turns out to be basically the
same but i'm
not going to go through the details
there's still a small step
in this case to deal with some technical
issues
but by high level basically in the
symmetric case you just use the same you
just use the same beta
and you get exactly you just apply
exactly the same algorithm and get
exactly the same kind of results
and another thing i should mention that
the matrix doesn't have to be
exactly low rank if the matrix is
well approximated by a random r matrix
then you have a remainder term
that's the one a minus max i
is a matrix that's by removing the first
arc
principal components what's left so as
long as this term is small
you still have good recovery
and the result turns out to be useful
for other problems of interest
and if we apply this result
to face retrieval and many of you must
have heard of face retrieval
and if you haven't heard of that that's
fine
it's basically when you do linear
regression you take square instead of
just the linear term so in this state in
this case you are still
trying to recover the vector as a signal
vector theta
and if you measure the signal with
gaussian measurements so if
if beta iid gaussian gaussian then you
can
apply exactly the same method by using
a small trick so you rewrite
the inner product squared to be in this
matrix form
then the problem is equivalent to
recovering
a rank one matrix and then you apply the
method and you get a bound
and basically you get this sort of bound
for free and by the way theta itself is
not identifiable because you take
absolute value then squared
so you have to match with the with the
best psi
and the problem has been solved before
by using different techniques by
emmanuel candice and xiaodong li
and you can see that in terms of the
results that the difference
between this and that the difference is
in this minimum
and typically n is much larger than
this term is very small typically that
means that by using our results
actually you can recover it better and
it can also be applied i'll be very
quick with this one
that it's a standard problem in
statistics you have iid samples you want
to estimate the covariance matrix
and if the covariance matrix is spiked
meaning that
it's identity matrix plus a low rank
matrix then you can use pca to solve the
problem
but the question is what if we only
observe
the projections of a high dimensional
random vector it turns out that by
applying our method
you can also recover that or estimate
the covariance matrix only based on rank
one-dimensional projections so i'll skip
this one
and because i want to mention two a few
other problems
and one problem is the so-called
structured
matrix completion so you have low rank
matrix and
every time you observe instead of random
entries you observe
random rows and random columns
and that problem is related and also
it's quite interesting
to solve another problem
and rob is here and is that you want to
estimate
the covalency matrix of a data matrix
called
x but you don't get to observe
this x you observe a projection of x so
a times
x sketch the version of this but you
still want to estimate
the covalence matrix and there are also
other problems like pca based on
projections instead of
original sample and
one last problem is covariance matrix
estimation
based on incomplete data and i guess
i'll just stop here and take some
questions thank you
okay let's thank tony
gaussian sampling measurement
do you think that it could be impossible
to compete with sufficient statistics
with lower storage i
don't think so i don't know for sure but
i don't think so
there's still so yeah i was uh curious
about that last comment about
missing data what exactly what kind of
model did you have in mind
you have a data matrix x then you want
to estimate the covariance matrix
now you don't have the full matrix you
only have a valley
this is say they're missing at random so
you don't get
to see all those entries you see certain
entries of the sample covariance exactly
it's like data
it's like matrix compression but you are
not trying to complete the original
matrix you want to estimate the
covariance matrix
okay maybe one might be
because in our setting we only generate
random vectors
i think it's possible to extend that
plus one minus design to also spots
yeah okay let's thank tony again thank
you